hello and welcome to this video playing
like 1 1 4 if he plays a move I don't
know maybe not I would have been nice
one it's got a decent rating but doesn't
look like it came aboard it but so
that's not good
ok maybe I can get a quick game started
and don't need to start an entirely new
video if I get a game quickly it would
be nice ok he ever got it Ashwin Wow
ok let's go when you fall again and
often times yeah I can't let's do it the
most power variation there a couple of
moscow variations around not a couple I
know of to this one and line and in the
semi Slav
yeah this is an absolute main line of
this Moscow black is going for a fee and
kiddo
and white is sending up Amarok see bind
if you know my videos you will not be
surprised that I figure that I feel that
white is slightly better always love the
maracas see white is just like such a
such comfortable position to be in
okay so just want to think about it a
little bit
he's got b5 on the cards yeah I think
you can go Queen d3 in this position I
just take such a bit surprising
yeah 95 is more of what I expected him
of course 90 X t4 is not it's not a
terrible move or anything I was just
more thinking about 95 95 Queenie to be
595 was mine was what I expected
Queen to c7 okay wants to go to a5
presumably and I think this this is a
generally useful move so let's do it
I wonder if b5 is an option here b5
takes e5
maybe I mean against b5 I always have
moves like Knight d5 or Bishop takes f6
the idea of King edge one is actually
very simple take a 695 and ruin black's
pawn structure and okay he reacted to to
the Satyam mechanical epoxy one so no b5
from d5 oh really how do you cover that
form how do you cover that pawn now yeah
I guess you don't
oh is that a technical trick that I
don't see it I don't don't really
believe no Knight moves I can take c7 I
probably go Queen a five to not trade
Queens and at least pretend to have some
compensation
okay the move before probably does not
help all that much let's see what is
that what is good here I probably should
move the Queen away from the six thing
like Queen d2 or my Scott 95
yeah the Queen Isis is nicely placed on
e3 for example 95 Queen you 3ss going to
be okay
I mean it's it's it's very nice that he
gave me the d6 bomb and you still have
to witness that's a surprising choice
hmm didn't expect that I mean I don't
have six I'm not quite sure what it is
doing it's looking at tons of protected
squares maybe wants to go night aged 5
to f4 or something I mean I always
forget that I can draw here during the
game but it doesn't it doesn't really
work I mean currently I have a
discovered check but I went to he went
to b2 in order to maybe use the spinning
situation yeah so here I get Queens
traded at least with Knight a form I
don't think he can avoid the trade and
why not
yeah wants to go to F forward and don't
want to allow it it was not strictly
necessary I could have played could have
played 93 but well G 3 doesn't hurt me
tonight it's not too bad on b2 by the
way it's just like it's covering c4
where are you going with this where's
the night going it's got some funky
night moves in this game I mean okay
yeah you cannot stay on h5 forever but
ah I wants to go to d4 it's something
that I should have anticipated I mean
there is a huge drawback I have a square
myself and d5 is about the best square
possible yeah I mean I want to undermine
his pawn on e5 so that he's got some
problems maintaining the knight 94 I go
rook f1 putting pressure on every F ow
it's not much fun um okay another idea
that is quite interesting as here it's
probably a bit outlandish so double
against this night and then play Knight
f6 King takes takes only five no this is
a no move let's do it and now
[Music]
maybe something like that it's flexible
[Music]
okay so
let's do it get a pesum okay why can I
not take it don't get it
I don't think there was a reason why I
couldn't take it okay let's push the
night back it doesn't have a safe Square
now anymore
okay don't want to run into a ton of
chicks but it's hard to hard to prevent
which is going back okay
yeah that should promote
yeah okay so let's have a look
we had a theoretical position here for
sure I wasn't quite quite certain how to
continue probably that's more than one
option Queen d3 should be okay though
one important point is said after 95
Queenie to be 5 I have 95 and I'm
threatening this so he basically has to
take on d5 and then we get this
transformation which is I think quite
quite ok for me he's 6 as possible and
here this is an interesting moment
because f4 you know no squares but you
can actually take and this is the player
position for black to say the least yeah
I've looked at this in mind in my
accessible efore repertoire so we did
not do that
he took him I mean by the way of course
after he 6 I don't go ahead for I just
take and play this I dried a slightly
better putting pressure on the pawn
ok so but he took on d4 played Queen c7
yeah King h1 is not strictly necessary
but it's a convenient move and E 5 okay
so ii v and v 5 was the problem with the
smooth yeah and it's true I really
didn't think about this move order huh
that's a bit of a problem I mean it
seems like I'm okay in a scenario like
that but it's not really an advantage
yeah maybe a very slight one here with
the bishop being a little bit stuck but
cannot be much so king h1 was a bad
decision I have to play a more
prophylactic move I don't see one maybe
okay okay
so then e 6 was basically not taking
advantage of my my my bear move but was
also weakening
yeah d 6 fatally say 1 net pong but the
engine is actually not even all that
enthusiastic about it so 95 that was
what I expected 9 F 6 is not good I
think but I thought that this should be
quite ok but should be 5 for Kim I had
the Becker again I cannot take it this
is important if I take it I thought rook
e1 whoops e3 seems to be stronger okay
yeah yeah I mean I cannot do this that's
made yeah so I dropped I dropped this
piece I can still fight a little bit I
mean it's lost but so um but okay then
this is even more powerful immediately
taking care of the of the back rank yeah
so yeah then b5 as strong if I cannot
take probably this is equal yeah we'll
probably trade down okay yeah Knight f6
Knight f6 it's just not good at it
deserves no no purpose on that square
yeah I know a for let's get rid of the
best place piece that black has it was
the Queen and now you should reroute the
Neue this is just losing more time just
centralize it here I get get the d5
square it should be a fairly fairly
simple win you played b5 giving me
giving me that porn
and out before was a bit bit bit in bit
weird and we can just take it yeah maybe
I made some inaccurate choices there was
no time on the clock that's possible but
I don't think I spotted I'll be
surprised to see it you know I mean this
is a little bit of back and forth I
wanted to play with d3 but yeah but I'm
just going to promote him so it was was
kind of okay I think yeah an opening was
interesting King edge one was a bad
choice really AM that was bad
okay guys thanks for watching